[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA:
Hello, and welcome
to "Spanner Internals Part 2."
This is a second talk.
We had a talk yesterday called
"Spanner Internals Part 1."
That was around how sort
of Spanner internally works
and how it's evolved as a
system over time inside Google,
and then we externalize
it into the Cloud.
So today, we're
going to focus on one
of the critical systems built
on top of Spanner internally,
which is Google Cloud Storage.
But before that, let's
sort of start out
with, what is Cloud Spanner?
So my name is Deepti Srivastava.
I am the product manager
for Cloud Spanner, which
is our Google Cloud Platform
managed database offering,
which is offered on GCP.
And we talk about it as the
only Enterprise-grade, globally
distributed, and strongly
consistent database service
which is built
specifically for the Cloud.
And what does that really mean?
It means that this
database service combines
the benefit of
relational semantics
with non-relational
traditionally NoSQL
horizontal scale.
So we have schemas.
We have asset transactions.
We have SQL.
And we have the ease
of scalability and high
availability, such as
four nines of availability
for our regional
configurations, five nines
of availability for our
multi-region configurations.
And all of this is packaged
up in a fully managed database
service that runs on Google's
Cloud infrastructure.
So as I said, the special
thing about Spanner
that no other database system
in the world currently has
is the ability to do
asset transactions
and have strong consistency
even across WAN and across data
centers and across regions.
No other database
in the world today
can do actual
strong transaction--
a strong consistency
on transactions
when you start to put the
replicas in more than one data
center that are
actually separated
from each other through
a wider network fiber.
And that speciality
allows both our customers
who are using Cloud Spanner to
build interesting applications
on top of it that can
be globally distributed
while having
read-after-write semantics.
It also allows our
internal services
to build some very exciting
and differentiated services
on top of Cloud--
on top of the internal Spanner.
So we talk about internal
Spanner and external Spanner,
but what are the real
differences here?
So Spanner, internally
or externally,
is actually the
same infrastructure.
It's the same
binary it's running,
whether it's serving external
stuff or internal stuff.
The only difference
is the access paths.
So externally, we have--
when you're talking
to Cloud Spanner,
the access path is through
the Google Cloud Platform APIs
and through all the security,
and all those kinds of things,
whereas internally, we have
our own internal access paths.
And we keep the data
separated for obvious reasons.
We don't want to mix
external customer
data with internal data.
So obviously, all of
the security and privacy
and compliance aspects apply.
But in terms of,
are you giving me
a slightly different version?
We're not.
We're giving you the same
Spanner that we have internally
for our critical services.
The other differences
are in terminology.
So my colleague will come up
and talk about some of these.
But basically, externally,
we have Cloud Spanner nodes,
which we call Spanner
Servers internally.
And externally, we have
instance configurations,
which are the topology for how a
replication is done-- basically
a replication topology.
And this can be
regional configurations
or multi-region configurations.
For those who are
familiar with Spanner,
Spanner is inherently
replicated.
So we have three replicas
for regional and 5, 7, 9
replicas for
multi-region, depending
on which configuration
we've chosen.
And these things are called
sort of Spanner configurations
internally.
So as I said, essentially,
it's the same differentiated
technology that we use
internally and have
done for seven, eight,
nine years, which
is why we feel so
confident about hosting
our customers on
it in the Cloud,
because it's battle-tested.
It's hardened.
And most of Google's critical
services at this point
run on Spanner.
One of those critical services
is Google Cloud Storage, GCS,
which is a very popular service.
It's built on top of Spanner.
And because of Spanner's
strong external consistency,
as we call it, GCS
is able to provide
very differentiated set of
capabilities to its customers.
So to tell you
about that more, I'd
love to invite Denis, who
is our colleague here.
Denis, why don't you come up?
DENIS SERENYI: All right.
Thanks, Deepti.
So a little bit about myself.
I'm the tech lead for GCS's
metadata layer for Google Cloud
Storage.
And hopefully, you are already
somewhat familiar with Google
Cloud Storage and/or
maybe have even
seen one of our other talks.
But I'm going to
talk a little bit
about-- give you an overview
of what GCS is all about,
and then go into depth in how
GCS takes advantage of Spanner.
So GCS is object
storage made simple.
It's a central repository for
all your organization's data,
putting it under a single
consistent unified API.
And so GCS is able to store
a wide variety of data,
whether it be content-serving
data, whether it
be analytics data that requires
high bandwidth, or even
warm/cold storage,
or archival tiers.
It's highly reliable.
GCS provides up to four
nines of availability
and multi-regional storage.
It's extremely cost-effective.
GCS can store hot data, but
it also stores cold data,
offering a price per gigabyte
as low as $0.04 a gigabyte.
Or sorry, $0.004 a gigabyte.
And we just introduced
our archival storage tier,
which is as low as
$0.12 per gigabyte.
GCS is secure.
It's a great way of
keeping your data secure.
Its data is encrypted
at rest and in transit
when stored in GCS and were
integrated with Cloud storage
solutions like IAM and KMS.
GCS offers three
different location types.
There is what's called
regional storage.
And that's where your
data is stored redundantly
within one of our Cloud
regions across availability
zones within that region.
And that's really good
for analytics data.
This regional storage
is a great way
of ensuring that your data is
co-located with your compute
so you can get really high
bandwidth access to your data
within that region.
Our second location
type is what's
called multi-regional storage.
And that's where your data
is spread redundantly across
multiple regions
within a multi-region--
a multi-region being
US, Asia, or EU.
And this is really great
for content serving.
We have over 100
points of presence
where this data can
be stored, which
means that if you're
doing content serving,
oftentimes the data is located
very close to where it's being
requested, and so we
can minimize latency,
minimize bandwidth by
distributing it widely
across a multi-region.
And then the third location
type is dual-regional.
This is something that
we've introduced recently
that kind of combines
the best of both worlds.
Dual-regional is a
great way of ensuring
that your data is
located in two specific--
in a specific pair of regions.
And this way, you
can ensure that you
have really high bandwidth
access to that storage
within those two regions.
Say, if you want to use
that data for analytics,
but you can get higher
availability with dual-regional
than you can get with regional.
So if you need to have an
analytics application where
you need to potentially
failover between regions,
dual-regional is a great
way of providing that.
And Twitter is an
example of a user
that's using our
dual-regional storage right
now for analytics.
Vimeo is an example
of a user that's
using our multi-regional
storage for content serving.
So GCS provides a
lot of key features.
This is an example of four
key differentiating features
of GCS.
And what's important to
keep in mind is that--
as I'm going to go
into in more detail--
GCS uses Spanner heavily under
the hood in its implementation,
and all of these features are
in some way enabled by the fact
that GCS is using Spanner.
So let's talk about
the first one--
strongly consistent listings.
What this means is that when
you do an object listing in GCS,
you're guaranteed to see
exactly what's there, not
some partial view.
And this makes your applications
on top of storage much simpler
because you can rely on your
storage layer being consistent.
GCS offers geo-redundancy
within the system.
So as opposed to systems where
you have to sort of cobble
together geo-redundancy at
layers above the storage system
by adding replication and
cross-regional replication,
GCS offers that as part--
just in one package.
And we of course
leverage the fact
that Spanner's metadata
is geo-redundant
in order to provide this.
GCS is highly scalable.
So much like Spanner
is used internally
very heavily by
Google, GCS is also
used really heavily by
many systems across Google.
And so we are--
we've had to grow
to Google scale just
to support Google's
internal applications.
And so we expose that to
our Cloud users as well.
GCS is scalable to exabytes.
And the fact that we're using
Spanner as our metadata storage
within GCS really
facilitates this scalability.
So because we have a highly
scalable metadata layer,
it allows our storage system
to scale to these levels.
And GCS provides a
single unified experience
for all the variety
of data that you have.
So regardless of what
storage classes you're using
or what location types, there
is a single unified API.
And that is also
facilitated by Spanner.
Because we're using Spanner
as our centralized metadata
repository, it
allows us to expose--
for all of the
data that's in GCS,
it allows us to expose the
single unified metadata
layer on top--
API on top of that metadata.
So now let's dive
a little bit more
deeply into how GCS uses
Spanner under the hood.
So you're probably familiar
with the GCS core storage
abstractions.
And these are
buckets and objects.
Simply, an object is a container
for a collection of data,
like a file in a file system.
And objects have
a particular name.
There's also buckets, which
are collections of objects.
And both of these things have
associated metadata in GCS.
So there is bucket metadata
and object metadata.
And that metadata is stored
in databases in Spanner.
GCS is using, much
like Deepti alluded to,
GCS is using Spanner
much like any other user
is using Spanner.
It's the same system.
And so we're basically
using Spanner just as
an ordinary customer.
So I would say that
Spanner provides
four key differentiating
features that
are critical for
GCS's implementation
and critical for GCS's use case.
And the first one is
strong consistency.
And so what that means for
us in our implementation
is that when we do mutations
into our Spanner databases,
those updates are
immediately visible to all
of GCS's front end systems.
And that allows us to
provide our own user
visible consistency
semantics much more simply.
It's certainly possible
for storage systems
to offer the kind of
strong consistency
that we offer without a
strongly consistent database,
but that would add
tons of complexity.
Storage systems can do that
with coherent caching layers
or fancy request
routing, or having master
election in the storage system.
But we kind of don't
have to do any of that.
We don't have to deal with it.
We just put our
metadata in Spanner
and serve that metadata
out of Spanner,
and it just kind of takes
care of the consistency
issues for us.
Spanner has a really
simple programming model.
It supports single-row
transactions,
and we do mostly
single-row transactions.
But we also use
multi-row transactions,
multi-table
transactions, and even
multi-database transactions.
And this allows our system
to be much simpler in how
it interacts with metadata.
GCS is made up of many
independent components
under the hood.
And a lot of those components
are interacting actually
directly with metadata.
And so the fact that
all of these systems
can interact transactionally
in a variety of different ways
with our metadata databases,
it makes all of those systems
pretty simple, and it gives
us a lot of confidence
that our metadata is
correct and consistent.
The fact that Spanner supports
really high availability
is critical for our use case.
So we use geo-redundant
Spanner deployments.
And the fact that you only
need a quorum of zones
available at any one time
in order to be serving
is something that we rely on.
GCS is also pretty big.
So the fact that Spanner
has really excellent
horizontal scaling is very
important for our use case.
Simply put, when one
of our locations--
when the metadata in
one of those locations
grows to the point where
we need more resources,
we just kind of scale up
our Spanner instances.
And that's a pretty simple
administrative action.
And Spanner scalability
just kind of takes
care of the fact that
location needs to grow.
I'm sure that there
are scalability limits.
I mean, every system
does have them.
But we just haven't
hit those limits.
And GCS is already really big.
So just to give you an idea,
some idea of what kind of scale
we're talking about when we're
talking about how big GCS is,
this is an example of
one of our multi-regions
and some high-level data
points for how big we've
been able to scale
our Spanner databases
for this multi-region.
So we're talking about
trillions of database rows,
millions of queries
per second, millions
of mutations per second,
petabytes of logical data
stored in these databases.
We're using thousands
of Spanner servers,
even for this one multi-region.
And there is over 1,000
miles between Spanner zones.
So the fact that we have
been able to scale up
our databases and a Spanner
instance to this scale,
and we haven't sacrificed
our strong consistency
or high availability is
really pretty unique.
It's pretty cool that we've been
able to take advantage of this.
So let's return to
the earlier slide
where we were talking
about GCS's location types
and talk about exactly what that
means in terms of our Spanner
deployments.
For regional storage, we're
using a Spanner instance that
is entirely within a region.
And so just to keep in mind, we
use separate Spanner instances
for all GCS locations.
And so for regional, we
use a Spanner instance
that's within the
region and zones
that are within
different availability
zones of that region.
For multi-regional, we
use a Spanner instance--
I'm calling them
Alex in the slide.
That's what we call
them internally.
It's just a different name--
with zones that are
spread across the regions
within the multi-region.
And for dual-regional,
we use a Spanner instance
that has zones within the two
regions of the multi-region
plus a third region.
So now let's deep
dive into really
exactly how Spanner's
strong consistency is so
important for GCS's use case.
So I've already talked
about this a little bit,
but I want to go
into depth into how
important strong consistency
is for GCS users.
Simply put, it's much
simpler to build applications
on top of storage when the
storage system is consistent,
when you're getting a
complete view of what's
in your storage system
at any one point in time.
So as a specific
example, GCS offers
read-after-write
consistency, which
means when you write
an object into GCS
and then later try
to read it back,
even if it's one of
our multi-regions
and we're doing sort of
cross-region redundancies
with that data, we have-- we
provide a strong guarantee
that you read exactly
what you wrote earlier.
And it sounds kind
of obvious, like I
mean, I guess, really every
storage system should work
this way, but there's a lot
of storage systems out there
that don't actually
provide this guarantee,
that are only
eventually consistent,
especially when you're
talking about geo-redundancy.
And this makes
applications a lot simpler.
If you don't have
this guarantee,
you might have to
introduce retry loops
into your application.
I don't know.
If the object isn't there
and you try and read it
and it's not, then you might
have to just kind of like
wait and retry later.
Another reason why strong
consistency is so important
is that GCS is being used
as an organization's what's
called a data lake, which
means that there are
many applications that
are working together
on top of storage that's
centrally located within GCS.
And if all of those applications
don't have a guarantee
that they're seeing exactly
what's in that shared storage
system at a point in time, then
it also adds more complexity
to those applications.
They might have to
deal with the fact
that there is only a partial
view that they're seeing.
A specific example of this might
be like an analytics pipeline,
where there is one stage
of a Hadoop pipeline
that is producing a data set.
And that data set
is later consumed
by some other stage
of the pipeline, which
is doing additional
transformations on that data.
If that later stage doesn't
have a strong guarantee
that it sees everything that was
produced by that first stage,
it's going to be some extra--
you're going to have to deal
with that in your application
somehow.
And a lot of times it's
just hard to deal with that.
So in addition to strong
consistency provided by Spanner
being really beneficial
for our users,
GCS also takes advantage of
Spanner's strong consistency
within the
implementation of GCS.
So how many people
in the audience
are familiar enough
with GCS to know
what a compose operation is?
OK.
Not too many people.
So compose is an operation
that's provided by GCS.
And it's a way to take
several-source objects
and stitch them together into
a single-destination object.
This is typically used, say,
for uploading large objects
into the system.
You can upload the
object in pieces,
and then after the fact,
stitch all the pieces together
into a single object.
Now, compose clearly
is going to involve
some kind of a
multi-row transaction
here, because it's going to be
operating on multiple objects
and doing that atomically.
But compose also offers what's
called preconditions, which
means that for each of the
source objects that you
specify, you can specify that
the operation should only
execute if certain
preconditions are met.
For instance, the
objects have to match
a particular generation in order
for the operation to complete.
So clearly, here is a case
where strong consistency is
going to be really important.
We're going to want to
read the metadata for all
of these objects out
of Spanner and evaluate
these preconditions, and then
if the preconditions evaluate,
commit a mutation.
If we don't have strong
consistency guarantees
from our database,
it's kind of a lot
harder to implement
that operation.
So here's another
example of how we're
taking advantage of
Spanner's strong consistency.
So GCS has an FSCK, a
Filesystem Consistency Checker.
This is something that
most storage systems have.
It's a process where
in the background,
you have something-- the FSCK
checker is something that's
running in the
background and validating
that all of the metadata
in the storage system
is correct, that it's
free of inconsistencies.
And a lot of times,
FSCK checkers
want to do what's
called cross-checking.
So validate that the
contents of one database
is consistent with the
value in another database.
And in order to make these kinds
of checks simple within GCS,
we take advantage
of the fact that you
can take a consistent point in
time snapshot across databases.
And we have a strong guarantee
from Spanner that everything
that's in that database, even--
I'm sorry-- in that
snapshot, even if it's
multiple databases,
is exactly what was
in those databases at
that point in time.
So this would make our FSCK
cross-checking much simpler.
In this example-- it's
kind of a simple example,
but this is an actual check
that we have in our FSCK, which
is that if there is a table
of all of your objects
in a given bucket and
then a separate table
in a separate database that
shows the state of the bucket,
whether it's deleted
or not, pretty clearly,
if there's objects
in the bucket,
then the bucket
shouldn't be deleted.
So we want to validate that the
contents of this one database
as refers to this one bucket is
consistent with the information
about objects in the bucket.
So here's-- my third example
is that we're using secondary
indexes within GCS.
And the way that we take
advantage of secondary indexes
is to optimize the performance
of our background scanners.
So storage systems.
It's fairly common
for storage systems
to have background scanners.
And what these
things typically do
is things like
maintenance operations.
So you might have
a scanner that's
running over all
of your metadata
periodically and doing
maintenance on the data that's
represented by that metadata.
Another way that background
scanners are used
is deferred operations.
So if, say, you do a delete
on some entity in your storage
system, typically, that delete
is [? act ?] very quickly.
And it kicks off some
asynchronous work
to sort of like
actually clean up
the storage that's
represented by that
object that you're deleting.
And so that's sort of a
deferred action that's often
driven by a background scanner.
So by using secondary
indexes, and
in particular sparse
secondary indexes,
we're able to build
background scanners that
are much quicker at iterating
over our metadata, because only
the things that actually need
attention from the background
scanner are represented in
the table that we're scanning.
So in this example, we
have an object table.
And there is a column
in that object table
that represents the time
at which an update was
made to each object.
And it's only when
these objects have
been updated that the
background scanner actually
needs to pay attention
to those objects.
And so we use that
update time as the key
in a secondary index.
And then so that secondary index
is much smaller than the object
table.
And so the background
scanner is running
over that secondary index.
And it's much simpler, actually,
to implement that background
scanner because the
secondary index is
consistent with the
object table itself.
So the last thing that
I wanted to talk about
is just some of the
challenges that we've
faced when building our system.
And one of the challenges
that we do face
is something called hotspotting.
So what is hotspotting?
The thing is that every single
system has scaling limits that
apply to individual keys.
So hotspotting can occur if
you have an uneven distribution
of load within your system.
Say, for instance, you
have a table of videos.
And one of those videos
happens to be "Gangnam Style."
And that's represented
by one row in your table.
Clearly, that row is going
to be really popular.
And you're going to have to deal
with some kind of a hotspotting
problem on that row.
Now, systems can deal
with this by caching
whatever is in that metadata
and distributing it more widely.
We choose to not sacrifice our
strong consistency guarantees
while attempting to
deal with this problem.
But we have developed
some techniques
to deal with it that
I'm going to go into.
So just for some
background, hotspotting--
strong reads in Spanner
require going to the leader
to get the latest timestamp.
So that is going to
hotspot particular servers.
And if you aren't careful
about this in your application
design, it is something that
can limit overall application
performance.
So there are two
techniques that we
employ to minimize
the issues that
are created by hotspotting.
And the first one is
through schema design.
So if the hotspotting
problem that you're facing
is that there are
small ranges of keys
that can get much hotter
than other ranges,
say, for instance,
in this example,
a collection of objects that
are all very similarly named.
So they share a
given key prefix.
You can address any
potential hotspotting
that might occur on that
range of your key space
by just spreading it out
more widely in your key space
by applying what we
call a sharding factor.
So you can basically
compute a hash, maybe,
over the contents
of your primary key
and prefix the actual
primary key with that hash.
It's going to have the
effect of spreading out
otherwise co-located
keys much more widely.
And that spreading
is going to cause
these keys to tend to fall into
different Spanner splits, which
will improve your
ability to scale.
But keep in mind that
this kind of spreading
can come with a cost,
depending on your workload.
So if an important
workload for your use case
is sequential scanning
over your primary key,
then this kind of spreading can
make that kind of sequential
scanning a little bit more
expensive, because instead
of scanning just one small
range of your key space,
you now have to scan several
ranges of your key space,
depending on how you've
broken up your primary key.
So the other way
that we've mitigated
the issues caused
by hotspotting is
by using bounded
staleness reads.
Now, you might be a little
bit sort of wondering, OK,
I've been talking about
strong consistency
through this whole talk.
Now we're talking about
bounded staleness.
But you can actually-- the nice
thing about Spanner is that you
can pick and choose when you
can introduce bounded staleness
into your application
and where--
and use it only where
it won't jeopardize
the kinds of high
level semantics
that you want to provide
in your application.
So we don't use bounded
staleness everywhere.
We use it where it won't
jeopardize the semantics
that we want to
provide to our user.
And keep in mind that
bounded staleness reads
are actually much cheaper
than strong reads.
And that's because, typically,
bounded staleness reads
don't have to go to the leader.
Oftentimes, all of the replicas
in your Spanner database
are almost entirely up-to-date.
It's only just that
last small window
of transactions that
haven't yet been propagated
to all of the replicas.
And so even if you just
have a small staleness bound
in your query, it
will almost always not
have to go to the leader.
It can go to any replica.
And what's nice
about Spanner's API,
is that you can easily
specify how much staleness
you're willing to tolerate.
And Spanner will provide
a strong guarantee
that that staleness
bound that you provide
is adhered to strictly.
So here's an example
where we're using
bounded staleness reads in GCS
as a performance optimization.
And we're not jeopardizing our
strong consistency guarantees
by using bounded
staleness reads.
So what we're doing is we've
got some code in our system
that is attempting to determine
whether a bucket exists.
And so that's-- a bucket
is represented by a row
in our database.
So we first start by issuing
a bounded staleness read
for that bucket.
Now, almost all
the time, that read
is going to return success.
It's going to say,
OK, the bucket exists.
And at that point, you've just
issued a bounded staleness
read, and you're done.
Now, in the unusual
case, it's going to say,
that bucket isn't there.
And in that case, we
retry with a strong read
to make sure to differentiate
between the case
where it was just a
bounded staleness read that
caused that bucket to not
be visible versus the bucket
actually not being present.
So in an unusual case, we'll
retry with a strong read
in order to maintain our
strong consistency guarantees,
but we still get a big
performance optimization.
So to sum up, it's
been a lot simpler
for Google Cloud
Storage to build
our industry-leading
functionality, reliability,
and scale because
we've gone all in
on building our system
on top of Spanner.
And we take advantage of
Spanner's strong consistency,
its simple programming
model, its high availability,
and its ability to
scale horizontally.
[MUSIC PLAYING]